I feel like I'm learning a lot on this job.
It's very different than acting on a film.
That's a much more insular process.
It's important how you work with others,
but this I feel like I'm constantly learning
from other people.
Do you feel like you learn
from all the human beings you interact
with on your show, on your multiple shows?
Yeah, I think that's just a human thing.
That's something that you,
which especially for someone like myself,
I'm basically in real life when I'm Clark Kent,
I'm pretty much an introvert,
I have always been since I was a kid.
it's just, I like my own company.
But the beautiful thing about whatever set you're on,
whether it's a TV show or whether it's the game show,
you do get a chance to learn.
And I think as an actor or as a host or as just someone
in entertainment, you should always strive to learn
on a daily basis, just as a human,
you should strive to learn.
But even just for our job,
I learn from people every single day,
whether it's learning a character trait,
learning a cool new accent from somebody
that I met in a meeting
or watching be really cool to somebody else.
So I can go, oh, that's that's empathy at work,
so I can put that into use later on or learning a cool fact
that I can put into my improvisation
where I need a bit of useless knowledge
that just pops to the forefront.
And working on a game show really, really helps
because you meet people from all over the world,
all different races, creeds, and it makes you,
it stocks up your stores of knowledge.
Now, another thing I feel like I could pick your brain
about is co-parenting, which you've been so kind
to include us in your life.
And for those of us out here who are
in a co-parenting dynamic, the harmony that you
and your daughter Miley and you know, her mom have
is just so aspirational.
What is a good secret out there, maybe for people to know
to have that kind of harmony
in their own co-parenting dynamics?
Drew, I wish I could tell you.
There isn't a secret,
if that were the case,
I would have sold 15 million books already.
I would've read 'em.
I can tell you, right?
But I can tell you when it comes to our situation,
I would say work.
And it sounds like such a small thing.
It's like work, but what's pretty cool is,
that's my baby mama right there.
And that's her boyfriend, Jason.
And that's my daughter Miley.
When people look at our TikToks, right?
They see the picture of harmony
and co-parenting and making a blended family that you want.
We just sold a sitcom to CBS based on our family
because people started seeing our family
during the pandemic and went, oh my God, that's so weird!
Here's the thing.
And this is the thing that I even tell my writing
partners when working on the sitcom,
you see that TikTok,
and folks online go, oh my God, it's so aspirational!
What's your secret?
If you would've seen the five minutes before that TikTok-
Good.
The work it takes to get to that TikTok, just in life.
The yelling, the screaming, the fun, the tears,
the ups, the downs, the not being able to talk
to each other for a week because you can't see eye to eye.
You are trying to make another person happy
while caring for this little person.
You wanna strangle each other sometimes.
Those TikToks would not be possible
if we had not worked.
For me to be able to love Mandie
the way that I do and she loves me and she has my back
and we care about nothing more
than the wellbeing of this daughter.
And then for me to consider Jason a part of my family,
the work that that took, that's not for everybody,
because I don't think
that everybody has that love for the other person.
You should.
But I don't know if everyone can do it,
but if you can, the beautiful thing is you have
a family that you made and you have a child who
has two parents that show their love because they love you.
So that's my soap box.
I love it.
And I'm just such an advocate for keeping that love
and respect and a lack of tension away from your kids.
So I just loved that.
Really quickly, I know your daughter's about to turn 18
and thanks to TikTok and things like that.
What did you say to your daughter when she said,
"I want to go out and take a risk
and put myself out there"?
I said, "Go for it."
And the one piece of advice that I gave her is,
don't do it to be famous.
That's my problem with TikTok and social media.
And I sound like old man Brady
shaking my fist on my lawn.
But instead of looking at it going,
oh I can't wait till I blow up.
And I want followers.
Be good first.
If you're gonna sing, if you're gonna dance,
if you're gonna act, be really great at it.
And I really do believe that if you're great at something,
if you become an outlier, the other stuff will come to you.
So that's the only word of advice that I've given her
and she's taken it and she's run with,
and she's gonna be fine all on her own.
Well, I know she's gonna be fine because listening
to everything you say is so salient,
so wise, so sage.
I think you need to father us all, Wayne,
or brother or shepherd.
I don't know, but preach, speak, everything you're saying.
I'm like, absolutely.
I'm hanging on your every word, really and truly.
It is such a pleasure to get to know you.
Aww, thank you, thanks, Drew.
And watch "Let's Make a Deal" 'cause you already
are on CBS.
You check your local listings.
Thanks, Wayne.
(upbeat music)